i've got a lot of confidence in this
team because i spent the entire training
camp with them i know the features that
they have the things we can do and i'm
certainly anticipating us doing that um
like i said the last two weeks and the
endings of those have been uh
nothing short of uh of crushing but i
would say uh this team as close as they
are as tightly connected as they are um
you know they're gonna find a way to to
push through and uh and regroup and
find our own way of winning at the end
and we'll do that
dan quinn falcons coach i mean you have
to say something after a game like that
sometimes it's just words that come out
of your mouth so you can get the hell
out of there and go home and go to bed
that's how i would feel if i have a team
that
just can't hold a lead they cannot hold
a lead and it's gotten to the point
where it really does become a
self-fulfilling prophecy and there has
to be guys on that sideline that are
thinking here we go again
right the first points scored when
you're up 16 26 17. here we go again
yeah next thing you know it's going to
be 26 24 here you go here we go again
and you just have to wonder at what
point arthur blank the owner of the team
is going to finally pull the plug on
this
last year when they went to the break at
1-7 we all believed that dan quinn was
going to be fired during the season they
finished six and two
that
secured for him another opportunity yeah
now what do you do what do you do at 0-3
what do you do your buy isn't for a
while it's like week 10 or week 11.
and they've got a couple of games
against the panthers before they get to
their best that's right so
you know maybe but i don't know based on
how the panthers played yesterday maybe
they can't beat them either but there's
a point where you just have to stop the
bleeding
now it's not like you have fans
who aren't showing up for your games so
that's different right than a normal
year yeah that's a factor it seems
that's a fact this year because of that
you don't you don't have to you don't
have to worry about the fans staying
home they're staying home anyway right
but there's just something
that feels broken
that there's only one way to fix it the
problem is do you fix it by making dirk
cutter the head coach do you fix it by
making raheem morris the head coach all
these guys are part of the problem yeah
is making one of them the head coach can
all of a sudden help the team not blow
big leads i don't know but i feel like
at some point arthur blank's got to do
something yeah i mean i i hear you i i
do think you're right though like with
the no fans and then like if things were
really bad right the you we'd be playing
clips of like falcons fans booing them
and all that that like adds to the bad
bags on the head right exactly that all
add to the bad look and aura around the
football team to where you feel like
that like drums up the pressure but with
the pandemic and things like that it
does seem different
either way i wouldn't abort mission
quite yet uh if i'm arthur blank i would
not now they played the packers this
week and yeah i'm telling you right now
i'm picking the packers to win that game
but like you said on the horizon the
schedule is favorable and we've seen
that they can certainly be competitive
and play with some of these better teams
but the panthers the vikings the lions
the panthers the broncos
i mean it's not crazy
it's not crazy for the for me to think
they could sit there and maybe go on a
run and win five in a row after this
packers loss that they're gonna have
this week or something like that
but i think the bigger thing is this
mike
we've talked about in the offseason how
thin of a football team they are
right
they're not todd gurley's not special
anymore julio jones didn't play
yesterday it's like after early on and
they had a few tricks for calvin ridley
just like in the dallas game it's just
like where's the offense go
where does it go and there's no
toughness to run the ball to put a team
away i mean it's 26 to 10 and it's three
and out and three and out and three and
out and three and out and it's just like
hey here's chicago every four plays
here's the ball back and try to come
back on us oh wait you are going to come
back on us because our defense stinks
too
not a good pass rush can't cover anybody
man-to-man as you saw
so
you know
yeah you could blame dan quinn and all
those things too but the roster itself
has issues it's too top-heavy it's not
as talented as i think as we all view it
to be
and here we are you know two weeks in a
row where they've not been able to show
the toughness on offense or the
toughness on defense to close teams out
and that's concerning when you're an
owner of a football team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports